[Music]
foreign
all of you i have killed someone
if you weren't here you've been present
or worse
and your mutants they're dangerous
we know
[Music]
this place takes your greatest fear
it made you live through it
[Music]
scary are you doing
you've got to get better someday
stephen bear let's play a game
and your mutants are dangerous
they need to learn how to control your
[Applause]
[Music]
powers
i'm telling you about our new movie the
new mutants in just
60 seconds ready go i play danny a young
mutant who wakes up in a sketchy medical
facility run by dr reyes you're not
alone danny dany meets the other young
mutants being monitored there
rayne aliana roberto ansan dr reyes
wants to help them understand their new
powers so they have therapy sessions to
discuss their haunted past
what if i just want to go home sam you
remember what happened
yep therapy
but then things get weird
and they discover that they can't leave
this isn't the hospital it's a cage
as if being trapped in a creepy hospital
isn't horrifying enough
they have to face their fear when a
sinister force invades
they start to question dr ray's motives
you can't believe when i say so we're
trapped in here with demons and you want
us to stay trapped
it only gets worse from there
do they get answers go see the new
mutants to find out
get tickets now welcome back everyone
it's charlie
marvel is still getting ready to try and
release the new mutants movie as you can
see they're poking fun at themselves
with a lot of those promos we hope that
it comes out august 28th
there's a bunch of big x-men stuff
coming up in the mcu so we'll break it
all down
if you're new to the channel we're doing
the giveaway for copies of marvel's
avengers game i'll name a new winner at
the end of this all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with these characters
in the mcu if they want to bring them
back you can make all the jokes about
maisie williams and all these other
actors being so much older than when
they actually filmed the movie
years ago but they're still young enough
that they could come back in the mcu for
a long long time in new x-men projects
but they dropped a bunch of new footage
with them explaining their characters
most people are at least a little bit
familiar with the new mutants in general
the story of this movie is a loose
adaptation of that very first story of
them coming together as a team in
fighting demon bear they call it the
demon bear saga so obviously that's why
he's the main villain of this movie
danny moonstar is a native american who
lives with her tribe they dropped the
opening scene a couple weeks ago and the
opening scene is basically
demon bear coming to kill most of her
family in her tribe
[Music]
during this big crazy scene you see her
running out into the woods her father
tells her you stay here i have to go
back for the others
there's a very important reason why
she's so connected to the demon bear
character
because if you're a big dragon ball fan
you know all about how fusion works
demon bear is basically the fusion of a
couple other tribe members that was
created a long time ago but then became
twisted and evil
so demon bear in the context of this
movie is connected to her tribe
which is why he's so fixated on her is
demon bear trying to get revenge against
her tribe for what happened to him
the comic book gets way crazier but this
is basically marvel's first
real big horror movie that they're
trying to release so for those of you
that have wanted some scarier
darker mcu movies this is about as close
as we're going to get until we get to
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
even though scott derrickson left that
project and sam raimi came on i'm really
excited to see what mr spider-man is
going to do with it i'm happy to see him
come back to big comic book movies in
the marvel universe especially now the
spider-man
is in the mcu but i think that part of
the reason why scott derrickson left is
because he actually wanted to do a legit
horror film with doctor strange too
multiverse of madness and kevin feige's
like
nah dawg we're not going to be doing
that we're not going to be doing crazy
horror in the mcu maybe some pg-13
horror but not
hard r horror but the way they're
talking about the new mutants movie is a
little bit like one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
meets nightmare on elm street like
freddy krueger vs the dream warriors as
they wind up in this false reality
fighting this giant apparition but in
this case it's demon bear that they're
fighting like you literally see him
fighting magic inside the limbo
dimension most of you probably know the
new mutants characters through
magic most of the fan art of new mutants
floating around the internet
is of magic in colossus just doing
really crazy stuff
the really cool easter egg here is
because obviously this movie was made at
fox where the deadpool movies were made
she is actually the sister of colossus
so you could think of her as the sister
of this deadpool version of colossus
and sort of tying everything together
originally when they were making the
movie
the director josh boone said that fox
actually wanted them to connect this
much more to the mainstream x-men movies
than they had before
originally he said he wanted to do a
horror film with these characters but
wasn't really thinking about the larger
interconnected universe of the mcu or
the marvel movies or anything like that
fox came along and said please tie this
more to the x-men movies but that was
before the big disney buy out
so he said there were early versions of
the movie where the big
mainstream x-men characters actually
showed up during the film
especially the ending they were going to
be tying it to the hellfire club they're
going to be a bunch of big stuff
happening in the sequels with mr
sinister
but a lot of that actually changed
through the process as they started the
fox disney buyout deal
that was all spinning up as they were
editing the film so what happened is is
when box started to get bought out by
disney they said that you don't have to
worry about that anymore
kevin feige the marvel people were like
just make your marvel horror film do
whatever you want to with it
so if you heard about them doing
reshoots a long time ago that never
wound up happening
there were never supposed to be any
re-shoots that was only when fox was
going to make them add a whole bunch of
legit big hardcore x-men stuff to the
movie which obviously is not the case
now
i think the movie is actually better for
it just let him tell this story with
these characters and then if marvel and
kevin feige want to bring them into the
mcu later and reuse the characters they
can do whatever they want to we have
full-blown multiverse now you have magic
that can open portals between different
dimensions
so it's not like you have to bend over
backwards too much to explain how they
could wind up in a future mcu project
there's a little more footage of maizie
williams wolfsbane and some of the more
recent footage her going full werewolf
make all the game of thrones direwolf
jokes that you want
she was actually working on this movie
between some of the later seasons of
game of thrones that's how long ago they
were filming this
what i'm most excited to see though is
where they leave the movie because the
director said that it's relatively
open-ended
there are supposed to be teasers for
potential sequels because the director
josh boone said that he hopes that kevin
feige lets him make those sequels
i think a lot of that just depends on
how successful this release is
because most places theaters are still
closed movie tickets will go on sale
in a couple days as of me posting this
video so you'll just have to see if
there's a theater near you that's going
to be playing the movie
what i'm really hoping is though is that
at least a couple weeks after the movie
comes out in theaters
they do video on demand release either
through disney plus or somewhere else
places where you can't go see it in a
theater you probably saw a couple weeks
ago disney made this big announcement
about this special release for mulan
what they're going to do is they're
releasing it on disney plus september
4th you have to pay extra money to
get it but you get to watch it and if
you want to see it in a theater in their
theaters near you that are open they'll
also be
playing it in those theaters so they're
just giving you a lot more options
about how you see that movie so disney
is just going to gauge the mulan release
and see how it does financially and then
use that for potential future movie
releases
that's why a lot of people are wondering
if black widow is going to get a hybrid
release like that where they release it
partly on disney plus in places where
theaters are closed
but in theaters where you actually can
go see it in a theater
and let me know if you do plan on going
to see new mutants in a theater
congratulations will bates you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel
avengers giveaway video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here for that new hugh
jackman wolverine documentary video
and click here for my brand new video on
the spider-man 3 title
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you